Hi everyone, in this lesson, we're going to take a look at the outline for this course.
And then we're going to take a look at a review of PBRs and how they work with Unreal.
So let's get started.
So the first part we'll be looking at is an overview of real time PBR.
What is real time PBR?
So it's a bit of a review for what we talked about in our first class.
So just a refresher and some new concepts, or I should say tools and methodologies
that can help you.
Next, we'll look at creating parent materials, instant materials, and adding more features.
We'll look at, we'll have a review of parent materials and instance materials.
And then we're going to introduce you to a switch parameter and how that works.
Next, we'll take a look at creating mask materials.
That process, we'll be using the minus nodes and clamps, that'll be some new stuff
to look at.
And using the lerp node, we'll look at masking textures for materials using one
texture by using RGB channels.
And then finally, we'll wrap things up looking at material functions.
What are material functions?
Using function inputs, building animated materials in a function, and using material
function in parent materials.
All right, let's go ahead and get started.
Let's go ahead and take a look at an overview of material theory in real time PBR.
Now review.
We've talked a bit about this in the first class, but what is real time PBR?
Many people from an offline render will find this difficult or at least tricky to understand
in the fact that we're being able to update some high quality materials on the
fly without having to send them to a renderer.
So that's because we use a unified light and shading system.
It approximates lights, real life behavior, physically accurate,
and uses real physical measurements such as Lumen, Lux, inverse square law,
energy conservation, et cetera.
It's more intuitive and consistent and produces a more accurate and more natural look.
So basically what we're talking about is the difference between things that are not
metal and things that are.
You can think of it as things that are flat in nature,
going all the way to things that are highly reflective.
So here's a nice little chart that I've given to you that shows you color wise
what you can do to imitate some of the things that you would see in real life
and in real nature.
So color info always has a range.
There are no pure whites or blacks in nature.
Although science is trying to get closer to that.
Keep in mind, roughness is key in defining the look of the material
as in selling its real world equivalent.
So that roughness is going to be key between shiny metal, rusty metal,
old leather, new leather.
Those are really, it's a really huge determining factor,
but there's also spec, which we mentioned in the first class,
which can add to the look,
but you gotta be careful because you have to bounce between spec and rough
and make sure they're not canceling each other out
or competing in some way.
So you'll see here again, a review of metallic.
Here's the range is zero to one typically.
And then you'll see here is roughness.
Both are very complimentary when working with your materials.
And you, again, you can have a defined texture
in these areas to help push that look
for what you're working with.
Here's some additional notes
when it comes to physical materials.
That's it with this course.
In the next course, we're gonna look at parent materials
and instance materials.
And in the case of adding more features
to those materials.